[Musique]
la demoiselle qui a réussi tous les
concours normale supérieure centrale
polytechnique
une première c'est tout les compos vous
avez réussi cette année ce sont les
seuls que j'ai passé vous avez bien
passé puisque vous êtes en bonne place
la bonne place et c 'est c'est sa
seconde c'est le pire soit à venir à
centrale c'est très dur pompe
actuellement
maintenant que c'est terminé vous avez
pas tout à fait dix neuf ans il ya
combien de temps que vous réussissez
tout ce que vous entreprenez
c'est la première année que je passe des
concours jusqu'au lundi 3 jusqu'à
maintenant ça s'est quand même passé ses
examens auparavant le bas que c'est tout
avec une mention je présume oui parce
que jusqu'à présent vous avez toujours
passer votre vie derrière un pupitre à
l'école et puis chez vous un bio rouge
de travail pour en arriver là où est-ce
qu'au contraire vous avez vécu
apparemment comme tout le monde je crois
que j'ai vu que comme tout le monde oui
j'ai l'impression d'être une jeune fille
de la maison qui fait la pige aux
garçons dans tellement ça vous gêne pas
ça ne vous ça ne vous trouble pas ça
inquiète sur l'avenir on n'avait pas
peur sauf c'est inquiète la fille de
l'entraîneur n'a pas l'impression qu'on
vous prenne un peu pour un monstre et
qu'on s'éloigne de vous des choisi une
école de garçons puis en plus une école
ils ont militaire est ce que pour vous
c'est vrai que je pense pas que ce soit
pour moi c'est pas le principal le
service militaire que je vais faire à
l'école surtout tu choisis politique ni
ses causes de fin des débouchés qu'on a
parce que finalement on peut faire ce
qu'on veut en sortant c'est bien la
recherche ou un métier d'ingénieur elle
vous serez vol
vous courez les magasins est ce que vous
occupez un petit peu
ça vous arrive de vous surprendre devant
une glace la mode vous intéresse vous
sentez président coup vraiment
je me sens pas anormales parce que j'ai
réussi son concours de polytechnique et
datant cette fois estimé difficile
d'être à norma la centrale et à
polytechnique
[Musique]